another day another possible piece of
the obstruction of justice case against
president Donald Trump CNN is now
reporting that when Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein went to the White
House a couple of months ago in December
about a month and a half ago Donald
Trump wanted to know from rod Rosenstein
number one where is the Trump Russia
investigation going which is already a
totally inappropriate question but more
shockingly Trump wanted to know whether
the Deputy age v-rod Rosenstein was
quote on my team referring to on Trump's
side I guess which reflects so poorly on
Trump's understanding of how the Justice
Department and FBI are supposed to be
independent entities able to carry out
investigations unencumbered in order for
them to be credible Trump says he's
about law and order and the rule of law
yet he has total disregard for how this
is all supposed to be carried out and
the report says that Rosenstein
responded to Trump of course we're all
on your team mr. president which is
actually a pretty slick response because
Trump probably hears rod Rosenstein say
that and he thinks oh rod Rosenstein is
telling me you're safe more than likely
and we're kind of guessing here if rod
Rosenstein says of course mr. Trump were
all on your team he probably means we're
all part of the Justice Department that
operates under the guy you appointed
jeff Sessions right I don't think yeah
you're all in the country's team your or
or on the country's team sure certainly
so this is the latest in a long and
growing list of obstruction like
behavior by Donald Trump he fired James
Comey to try to stop the Russia
investigation he tried to push out
Attorney General Jeff Sessions four
recusing himself on Russia related
matters didn't work he tried to pressure
jeff sessions to fire
deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe who
ultimately did resign he ordered the
firing of special prosecutor Robert
Muller which didn't happen and we also
learned in the last 24 hours that Donald
Trump is thinking of trying to prosecute
special prosecutor Robert Muller to stop
the Trump Russia investigation it's just
not how innocent people
I don't know what else to say or how
many times to repeat it this is not how
an innocent person behaved and this is
quite literally another loyalty pledge
she did the same thing to James Comey
and of course right home he refused to
do it
what did Comey do we remember the
details of that when he asked he said he
like you would pledge his loyalty to the
FBI or you know something more vague
yeah yeah and I don't know maybe yes the
same thing of Jeff Sessions - well
probably wouldn't recall yes of course
that's just not something sessions would
be able to remember I I kept reading
further and further into the CNN report
and there's another stunning little
nugget from it which is that sources say
Trump believes Rosenstein was upset that
Robert Muller wasn't selected to be the
FBI director and responded by saying if
you're not gonna make molar the FBI
director I'm going to make them special
counsel which is truly a type of
paranoia that should concern all of us
regardless of party when we see it in
the President of the United States and
it's consistent with narcissistic
personality disorder lack of trust like
an unending lack of trust is a common
characteristic of real bona fide
narcissists which Donald Trump does
appear to be but the broader question is
how many instances of the same pattern
do we need before the country and
Republican lawmakers will not only see
it for what it is but admit that hey
this is bad and it's bad for the country
forget about the committed trumpet voter
right they're basically a lost cause we
figure that out but the pattern of
obstruction is so clear that it must at
some point get to where most of the
country and lawmakers say no more right
like at a certain point if there's no
such awakening it'll confirm that
Republican lawmakers must see it but
they just don't care and I would argue
that's worse than then actually being
blind yeah it's a complete disregard for
the separation of powers for the
independent judiciary I know that he
nominated chris ray to be FBI director I
don't think chris ray would give him a
loyalty pledge either but he's demanding
it
it seems he demanded it from Rod
Rosenstein do you think Ray has been
sufficiently independent so far I mean I
he has yeah I think that he generally
has been it's it's absolutely stunning
and I don't know what the depths of it
are I don't I don't really know when it
will end but it is at this point we
don't know until there are actual
charges against who knows who we can't
say with any certainty that X crime or Y
crime was committed so when I talk about
obstruction of justice I'm really using
the sort of colloquial understanding of
it there's no question that Donald Trump
has made half a dozen moves that we know
about and who knows how many that we
just haven't found out about yet with
the goal of getting in the way of the
Trump Russia investigation whether you
want to call it criminal obstruction of
justice I'm not getting to that there
are people who are going to figure that
out if they're allowed to Robert Muller
being one of those people but there's no
question that every intention every move
the intention of each of these moves has
been to prevent a full and complete
investigation into what took place and
we should all be very very worried about
that send me your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show the David
Pakman show today is partially sponsored
by brilliant which is a great online
service that allows you to master
interesting concepts in math science and
engineering by solving fun and
challenging problems and unlike other
learning sites when I'm using brilliant
I'm actually learning by working
hands-on with real-world scenarios and
problems you solve challenging puzzles
that have been carefully designed by
expert educators and professionals from
all over the world they don't go too
fast they don't go too slow they take
you step-by-step through the topics that
you're interested in at your own pace
one of the principles of learning at
brilliant org is effective learning is
active and that makes a lot of sense
because we do learn a lot of new things
in passive ways watching YouTube videos
for example which is great and it's
something I do all the time but that
gets you to a certain level and that's
where brilliant picks it up don't learn
by watching but learn by
actually doing and you can get started
right now by signing up for free at
brilliant org slash David Pakman and the
first 200 people who visit brilliant org
slash David Pakman will get 20% off an
annual premium membership that's
brilliant org forward slash David Pakman